President Trump has been here in New
York all week on business at the UN but
he returns to Washington later today
to face a historic political fight the
president told reporters he'd consider
releasing records of all contacts
between his administration and Ukraine
to prove he's done nothing wrong
Paula Reed was at mr. Trump's news
conference yesterday Paula I'm really
curious is that the president's story
changed since we've seen this memorandum
of the call with the president of
Ukraine well the president would not
directly answer questions about whether
his call with the Ukrainian president
was appropriate and for someone who
usually relishes the opportunity to spar
with the press he took just four
questions before making an abrupt exit I
didn't do it you take a look at that
call it was perfect
president Trump defended his
conversation with the president of
Ukraine and issued a new call for
transparency I fully support
transparency on the so-called
whistleblower information but in a
meandering press conference he deflected
when pressed if it was okay for an
American president to ask a foreign
leader to investigate a political rival
Democrats did this hoax during the
United Nations week it was perfect but
throughout a busy week at the UN the
president took every opportunity to
spread unsubstantiated claims and attack
his political enemies Joe Biden in the
Senate corrupt
during their meeting Wednesday the
Ukrainian president came to mr. Trump's
defense nobody pushed it but Democrats
argued the power imbalance was implicit
according to a summary of the calm after
the Ukrainian leader brought up a u.s.
defense spending mr. Trump told him I
would like you to do us a favor he asked
his counterpart to find out what
happened with CrowdStrike the company
hired to investigate the Russian hacking
of the DNC servers he also asked the
Ukrainian leader to look into former
vice-president Joe Biden and his son if
you're a Democrat you have automatic
protection no evidence has yet emerged
that former Vice President Joe Biden or
his son hunter did anything illegal it's
such a blatant abuse of power
last night Biden made his strongest
comments yet on impeachment it seems to
me it's awful hard to
avoid the conclusion that it is an
impeachable offense and a violation of
constitutional responsibility president
Trump has repeatedly pointed to Biden's
efforts to push out a Ukrainian
prosecutor even describing the man
Victor shokhin as very fair and very
good however experts tell CBS News
Shogun was known internationally as very
troubled and deeply corrupt Biden
insists his efforts were to root out
corruption not to defend it Paulo
looking at the clock here we're less
than two hours away from the house
focusing in on this complaint what do we
know at this hour about the
whistleblower and how did it get to
McGuire we know the whistleblower is
really concerned about retaliation which
is why he went to the inspector general
went through these channels we also know
that the government has found this is
someone who supported the president's
political rival in the last election but
the Inspector General still found this
complaint credible
now that whistleblower heard this
information secondhand this person was
not on this call heard from other White
House officials that the president had
apparently applied pressure on a foreign
leader that whistleblower was concerned
brought to this to the inspector general
the Inspector General was concerned this
could have been a campaign finance
violation so they took all of this to
the Office of the Director of National
Intelligence they looked at this
complaint and they said okay clearly we
have issues of privilege we have issues
of confidential information we need to
go to the White House we need to go to
the Justice Department the Attorney
General was also mentioned in this call
Paula yes he was what exactly is the
Attorney General's Office Justice
Department implicated in this if at all
there's a lot of big questions about
that right now because the president
mentions Barr in the call but Barr
issued a statement denying very narrowly
and very specifically that the president
ever asked him to have the Ukraine
investigate Biden or have him reach out
to the Ukraine but the question is have
you ever discussed this with the
Attorney General and we know the
Attorney General had a question on the
hill several weeks ago where he was
asked has the president ever asked you
to investigate anyone he could an answer
he said he didn't know so he can't
answer the question yesterday the
president only took four questions I
didn't have a chance to ask him but
there were questions about whether the
president has discussed this or used US
law enforcement as well for a president
who likes to jab people for being
low-energy he seemed very subdued there
low energy yesterday I'm curious what
your thoughts were as someone who was in
the room and then Democrats read this
report and say it's damming Republicans
read it and say oh really nothing to see
here I think that's what frustrates
people the two extremes how do you
explain his low energy his mood
yesterday it was surprising look we're
all tired after this week right but it
was surprising that he had an
opportunity to really take some of these
tough questions and spar which we know
he loves to do get out there defend
himself and he didn't really do that he
talked it went on for a little over an
hour he talked for most of that time he
only took four questions he even tried
to insist that we ask him only about
things that happen at the UN guys the
president took every opportunity at the
UN to forward these allegations a very
unusual press conference even paused at
one point to defer to Pompeo
not quite clear why he was so tired but
not as usual South it's very interesting
Thank You Paula